Let's break down the process
of parsing JSON.
JSON, or JavaScript Object Notation,
is a popular way of describing
a collection of key value pairs.
The keys could be
represented as strings, and
the values can be other strings,
numbers, arrays, or even dictionaries.
For the web services that we'll
interact with in this course,
as well as many others, we can use JSON
to pass data to and from our apps.
For now, I just want you to focus on
getting JSON data and then parsing it.
We can break this process
down into three steps.
First get the raw JSON data.
Second, parse the JSON data into
a usable foundation object,
such as an NS dictionary or an NS array.
And third, grab the data
from the foundation object.
These steps will make more sense in
code, so let's demonstrate them now.